happy belated birthday
thank you so much just like you had the
most epic special week of all time and
that Wells was just the prince charming
of dream he was what was the most
special part for you oh my gosh the
entire week was um amazing going in a
helicopter I was like what club 33 was
probably my favorite
I like dressed up really fancy and he
was wearing a student look dashing and
the food was amazing
so probably probably that I did that of
the helicopter people calling new
relationship bowls
what is it about him that you find so
amazing the whole relationship goes
things I feel like that is said about a
lot of people a lot of different
relationships a I don't know yeah the
greatest what makes him and you so
compatible do you think we're the same
person with different genitalia Modern
Family star Sarah Hyland radiated in red
at kiss FM's I Heart Radio jingle ball
in LA on Friday clearly feeling the
holiday spirit the actress revealed to
eat tea for epic pitch for next year's
show I want to get three of my
girlfriends okay and dude Jingle Bell
Rock from Mean Girls that would be so
iconic I want that
[Music]
got your wieners thing and then they're
like but because she thinks SS and and
then we can have like then we can have
like Julie Bowen in the audience so
Cameron just like okay done sold
when Ryan Seacrest comes back here I'm
going to relay the message to him
Ryan make us happen we need that to
happen
[Music]
you